[Aplausos]
otro motivo de indignación en colombia
cientos de ciudadanos se reunieron en
bogotá en rechazo a las múltiples
denuncias de abusos sexuales
presuntamente cometidos por la policía
el plantón se convocó tras conocerse la
noticia del suicidio de una joven que
había denunciado un día antes haber sido
abusada sexualmente por parte de agentes
antidisturbios que la detuvieron con un
uso excesivo de la fuerza
me siento rota
por lo que pasó ayer la ciudad de
papayas una de nuestras compañeras fue
violentada sexualmente por cuatro
agentes del esmad
ella decidió quitarse la vida pero
nosotras yo estoy convencida de que ese
es un crimen mezclado la policía asegura
que se trata de una noticia falsa y
dicen que la menor de 17 años habría
sido entregada a su familia horas
después de su detención la menor nunca
pisó instalaciones policiales por el
contrario una vez se conocen los hechos
y se realiza el procedimiento por parte
de las unidades policiales la menor de
edad es trasladada a las instalaciones
de la uri de la fiscalía general de la
nación horas después la policía informó
que los cuatro agentes fueron separados
de sus funciones y que puso en manos de
la fiscalía la investigación del caso la
ong local temblores ha registrado 16
casos de violencia sexual contra mujeres
en el país por parte de la policía desde
el inicio de las protestas el gobierno
colombiano sigue sin condenar de forma
firme los 2.110 casos de violencia
policial documentados en las protestas
según temblores y no se ha referido
hasta el momento a las denuncias de
violencia sexual contra mujeres por
parte de sus oficiales